more politicians in California are
endorsing efforts to directly resist
federal law last weekend Oakland Mayor
Libby Schaaf warned local residents of
imminent ice raids potentially allowing
several dangerous criminals to escape
now lieutenant governor Gavin Newsom who
hopes to become the governor soon was
Jerry Brown leaves is calling for other
local leaders to do the same thing
because that'll make the state a lot
better of course it will Travis Allen is
a California state assemblyman a
Republican gubernatorial candidate and
he joins us tonight
Nashawn thanks come on thanks so much
tucker pleasure being on so I haven't
lived in California in a while so I
don't really know the answer but does
anyone notice that the state the state
of California is an open rebellion
against the United States is that noted
out there you know Californians are all
scratching their head at what's going on
with Jerry Brown Gavin Newsom the
California Democrat Party I will tell
you right now you know don't believe
that the media reports ordinary
Californians are absolutely shocked it's
at what's going on in the streets of
California so I mean what do you think
the core problem is I mean California
was once the greatest state me and
people came from all over the world to
live there I mean look at popular media
from 50 years ago people sang about
moving to California people are fleeing
California now what changed exactly do
you think well you know what change is
decades of the Democrats running a
California Legislature you know as you
may have heard 39 in the last 40 years
the California Democrats have controlled
both houses of state legislature and
Jerry Brown and his father have
controlled California for 24 of the last
50 years so you know as this has
progressed we've started to see our
taxes go up our businesses leave our
people leave as a matter of fact we had
200 43,000 Californians leaving over the
last seven years taking 8 billion
dollars with them and now we're seeing
Oakland lawlessness where we have Xavier
Becerra the criminal Attorney General of
California openly threatening California
businesses that if you follow a federal
immigration law he's gonna prosecute you
and of course you've heard a Libby
Schaaf it's getting even worse now so
tell me a little bit about the quarter
million Californians who've left in the
past seven years I mean those are middle
class those are normal middle class
people right I mean the kind that you
former society around well you know I
can tell you very personally these are
my parents my parents have left the
state my brothers left the state my best
friend now lives in Texas where he
doubled the sizes house double the size
of his business and he pays no state
income tax
I'm also an investment advisor in
addition to be a California State
Assemblyman and I can tell you that my
clients all started in California
they're now in 22 different states
around the nation I mean do the people
who run the state have any do they know
this do they pay any attention I know
your tech sector is doing well and
you've you've got more poor people than
ever so you're sort of booming on either
end but are they worried about the
middle class fleeing you know if you
listen to Jerry Brown and Gavin Newsom
it's as if they live in a bubble they
absolutely do not see this but it's
understandable I mean if you were Gavin
Newsom the former mayor of San Francisco
and you had maps of human waste so
people could actually navigate through
your city hypodermic needles on your
sidewalk and actually now opening heroin
injection Center starting in July in San
Francisco I think it might make sense to
look the other way at the facts because
that's that really is the only
explanation California highest poverty
the nation one in five Californians
living below the poverty line highest
homelessness in the nation and I mean
the numbers go on and on they destroyed
something so beautiful and they should
be punished for it Assemblyman thank you
good luck